[Music]
the walking dead has been thrilling
viewers for over a decade with its
untold legions of shambling undead and
ruthless living antagonists but then out
of nowhere 11 seasons and over 150
episodes in something comes along that
makes fans raise their eyebrows in
disbelief this time the offending party
is the entirety of alexandria the safe
zone that first appeared in the season 5
episode the distance lately the
washington dc adjacent haven for the
survivors has had viewers scratching
their heads and wondering what the
show's writers are thinking at least
that's what's going on over on the
walking dead subreddit where discussions
regarding season 11 episode promises
broken quickly took a turn for the sassy
critical comments are being directed by
fans of both the people of alexandria
and the real world writers room that
keeps them there basically according to
the show's more vocal devotees nothing
about the place adds up when looked at
with any level of scrutiny it's a
well-established fact that
post-apocalyptic municipalities are only
as dramatic as their constant risk of
being overwhelmed by the undead that
said viewers have noted that alexandria
doesn't boast much consistency when it
comes to presenting its struggles
meanwhile the very fact that anyone
would stay in the safe zone perplexed
others one user rhetorically spoke on
behalf of the people of the settlement
saying i think we should stay in
alexandria with its half-burned
buildings walls that seemingly leak in
walkers at an amazing rate where our
land is destroyed and there are no new
resources to be found if nothing else it
goes to show you that the real estate
market is cut throat even after the fall
of civilization
frustrations with the situation
surrounding alexandria are nothing new
with many fans pointing to the whisperer
wars the start of the problem around the
conclusion of the story viewers were
clued in on the idea that alexandria was
running low on supplies by the start of
the next season and seemingly out of
nowhere the safe zone was in an even
worse predicament than before with
around a month's worth of food left and
no option but to send an away team to
try and take back a reaper settlement
our people are about to starve i'm not
going back to my family having failed
the whole kerfuffle raises a lot of
questions why was retaking the reaper
settlement the best use of markedly
mortal resources was there nowhere else
worth checking out how did the community
let things get this bad without putting
any thought into finding more food and
more than anything why would the
survivors stay in alexandria if they
wanted to remain survivors while the
area might have been the best game in
town for a while boasting solar panels
and sustainable plumbing and a very
scenic windmill times have changed folks
have been pointing out issues with
alexandria for as long as the safe zone
has been on the show entire swaths of
reddit are dedicated to pointing out
gaps in in-universe logic when it comes
to the region with users claiming to be
engineers arguing with other users who
claim to be engineers over whether or
not the supports on the outside of the
wall would be better served on the side
where nobody could knock them down it's
a tension versus compression issue
apparently we don't actually know
despite an overwhelming enthusiasm for
souring the walking dead suite plenty of
fans seem willing to extend their
disbelief far enough that they see
alexandria as a perfectly acceptable
hypothetical spot to settle down and
teach their kids to aim for the hit in
another corner of reddit enthusiasts
hypothesized that much of what makes the
place enticing is either long-lasting
enough that the survivors wouldn't have
to worry about it as with the pvc used
in the plumbing were easily replaced or
reconfigured like the solar panels and
batteries in other words alexandria
might not be perfect but it's the
closest thing to a home our characters
have had for over half the show it seems
they'd rather build on that foundation
than go on another road trip at least
for now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]